[Music]
hi everyone thank you so much for coming
to the interval in in the middle of the
day I hope this is this will be
inspiring it will increase your
productivity having I'm sure stepped
away from a lot of busy things this is
this is a really special event we're so
appreciative to Neil he he fit us in on
his schedule amongst a busy busy tour
that was already going on so thank you
and thank you all for being here give
yourselves a round of applause to get us
started today I we've had a long
association with Neil and are a big fan
of his work and and happy to continue
that and also a really appreciate of
Neil because he was a contributor brick
starter and helped us to build the
interval so we're happy to welcome here
for the first time since we finished it
please give a big hand of applause
applause for long now co-founder Stuart
brand who's going to introduce Neil
I'm so used to saying good evening do I
have a sound by the way my amplifying
good you can hear me I can't there's not
a good evening deal it's barely
afternoon thank you for coming the
manual of civilization up here which is
still collecting is a body of books
meant to be useful for any civilization
wants to keep going for a long time or
if something bad happens be able to
start over basically from scratch and in
this library are a collection of
first-rate hard science science fiction
books all of Neal Stephenson's books are
in there including the new and
especially an at them which is you know
got a long now clock in the middle of it
and the current book has a restart
civilization aspect to it we'll talk
about that some but what makes Neal's
books I think especially accessible and
nerdism at its best is that it's really
engineering friction he very rarely
evokes miraculous well we can travel
faster than light or something like that
and in fact the current books far as I
know it has nothing miraculous in it
whatsoever everything plays out in terms
of orbital dynamics and ennoble
biotechnology and therefore is a
completely plausible engineering fiction
story that also doesn't have to imagine
at the beginning of far distant strange
future but pretty much starts from where
we are which is what civilizations
always have to do is start from where
they are
let's get Neil Stevenson up here to
start us from where we are
thanks Stuart and thanks for coming out
in the middle of a day when I was a kid
I used to ride my bike to the bookmobile
in Ames Iowa and check out whatever new
science fiction had come in that that
that week and at some point I checked
out a book whose name and author I've
forgotten which was a space art book it
was about a global catastrophe that
forced the people of Earth to construct
an ark and and send a small number of
survivors into space and I guess it made
a big impression on me because now
almost half a century later I've written
one it took me a long time because it
turns out that if you're going to make a
contribution to the space Ark subgenre
you have to come up with an incredibly
finely calibrated disaster scenario so
if aspirated comes out of nowhere
tomorrow and destroys the earth I can't
make a space Ark book out of that
because we don't have time to build the
Ark and if we see a disaster coming
hundreds of years in the future we'll
probably solve the problem instead of
going the hurt route so I have to be
predictable far enough in advance that
there's just enough time to build an ark
but not so far in advance that you could
just prevent it from from happening so
that's pretty hard so the that idea was
kind of dormant for quite a while until
about 10 years ago I was working part
time at Blue Origin which is Jeff Bezos
private commercial space company up in
Seattle and I was looking for a while at
the problem of space debris orbiting
junk that we've put up there since the
beginning of the Space Age spent rocket
boosters dead satellites things that
were dropped by astronauts on spacewalks
and it's all zooming around up there in
low-earth orbit and
occasionally two of these items will
collide with each other and and because
of their enormous velocities that means
they'll shatter and kind of spray out
smaller fragments and a whole family of
new orbits and the specter has been
raised by some or some space scientists
that this could become an exponential
process and suddenly over a short period
of time so many of these fragments could
be generated that it would render space
and no go zone we wouldn't be able to go
up there safely and the way that we've
become accustomed to so that was
actually not very useful as far as the
that company was concerned but it did
sort of set a bit in my in my novelist
brain and and it occurred to me that
that mechanism could be used to destroy
the world if if it could be implemented
on a much larger scale
all I had to do was get a whole bunch of
crap into orbit to reproduce that
phenomenon and so the way that I ended
up doing that was by blowing up the moon
so on the first sentence of the first
page of this book the moon blows up
suddenly and for no apparent reason
and separates into seven large chunks at
all they're all up there kind of
floating around the moon's former center
of gravity they're still orbiting the
Earth but if they're all kind of
drifting and and milling around at
random and there's a character in the
book named Dubois Jerome Xavier Harris
who's a astrophysicist at Caltech who's
a legit scientist but he's also a
science popularizer he's one of these
people who can go on the Today show you
know and talk about science in an
understandable way so needless to say
his doobs phone he go he goes by Dube
informally and his phone begins to ring
immediately after the moon blows up and
doesn't stop ringing for a long time
and so in the course of trying to calm
people down and try to you know get
people thinking about this as a
interesting science problem one of the
things he does is give names to the
seven big pieces of the moon and he
doesn't want to give him scary names
like Thor or nemesis
so he gives them he names them potato
head mister spinning a corn peach-pit
scoop big boy
and kidney bean and that lasts for about
a week until two of them collide at
random and kidney bean breaks in half so
now there is eight pieces instead of
seven and the scientist brain in him
says well if we can go from seven pieces
to eight pieces in a week how long does
it take to go from eight to nine and so
on and what implications might that have
so we joined the action I'm just going
to read for about maybe five minutes
here we join the action about four days
later he's meeting with the President
and some advisors at Camp David my
friend and colleague Bruce Sterling once
said that a thriller was a science
fiction novel that includes the
President of the United States so I
guess this is this is one of those it
seems very strange to just blithely
begin writing the president into a book
but that's what you do when you're
writing one of these so we need to stop
asking ourselves what happened and start
talking about what is going to happen
dr. Harris said to the President of the
United States her science advisor the
chairman of the Joint Chiefs of Staff
and about half of the cabinet he could
see that the president didn't like that
julia bliss clarity currently nearing
the end of her first year on that job
the chairman of the JCS was nodding but
president Flaherty was giving him a hard
squinting look and not just because of
the light coming in
the window from the skies over Camp
David she thought he was up to something
trying to shift blame trying to push
some kind of new agenda go on she said
then remembering her manners dr. Harris
four days ago I watched kidney bean
break in half Dube said the Seven
Sisters became eight since then we've
seen a near miss that could have
fractured mr. Spinney I would almost
welcome it said the president if we
could get rid of those ridiculous names
it'll happen
Dube said the question is how long does
mr. Spinney have to live and what does
that tell us he clicked a small remote
in his hand and brought up a slide on
the big screen heads turns toward it and
he felt a mild sense of relief at not
being stared at anymore by the president
the slide was a montage of a snow ball
rolling down a hill a fuzzy bacterial
culture growing in a petri dish a
mushroom cloud and other seemingly
unrelated phenomena what do all these
have in common they're exponential he
said the word gets tossed around a lot
by people who use it to mean anything
that's getting big fast but it has a
specific mathematical meaning it means
any process where the more it happens
the more it happens the population
explosion a nuclear chain reaction the
snowball rolling down a hill whose speed
of growth is pegged to how much it's
grown he clicked through another slide
showing plots of exponential curves on a
graph then to an image of the moon's
eight pieces when the moon had only one
piece the probability of a collision was
zero he said because there was nothing
to collide with Pete's darling the
president's science adviser explained
the president nodded
Thank You dr. sterling when you have two
pieces why then yes they can collide the
more pieces you get the higher the
chances of any two pieces banging into
each other but what happens when they
bang into each other he clicked the
control again and showed a little movie
of kidney beans breakup well sometimes
but not always they break in half which
means you have more pieces eight instead
of seven nine instead of eight and that
increase in number means an increase in
the odds of further collisions it's an
exponential said the Chairman it
occurred to me four days ago that it did
have all the earmarks of an exponential
process doob allowed and we know what
happens to those president flirty had
been watching him intently but she now
flicked her eyes over at pete's darling
who made a dramatic upward zooming
gesture with one hand tracing the
profile of a hockey stick when an
exponential hits the bend in the hockey
stick curve Dube said the result can be
indistinguishable from a detonation or
it can look like a slow steady increase
it all depends on the time constant the
inherent speed with which the
exponential thing happens and on how we
perceive it as humans so it might be
nothing said the Chairman it could be
that a hundred years will pass before we
go from eight chunks to nine chunks Dube
said nodding at him but four days ago I
got worried that it might be one of
those things that looks more like an
explosion
so my grad students and I have been
crunching some numbers building a
mathematical model of the process that
we can use to get a handle on the time
scale and what are your results dr.
Harris I assume you have some or else
you wouldn't be here the good news is
that the earth is one day going to have
a beautiful system of rings just like
Saturn the bad news is that it's going
to be messy
in other words said Pete's darling the
chunks of the moon are going to keep
banging into each other indefinitely and
breaking up into smaller and smaller
pieces spreading out into a system of
rings but some rocks are going to fall
on the ground and break things and can
you tell me dr. Harris when this is
going to have
over what period of time the president
asked we're still gathering data tuning
the models parameters Dube said so my
estimates could all be off by a factor
of two maybe three Exponential's are a
tricky that way but what it looks like
to me is this he clicked through to a
new graph a blue curve showing a slow
steady climb over time the timescale at
the bottom is something like one two
three years during that time the number
of collisions and the number of new
fragments are going to grow steadily
what is B fr asked Pete's darling for
the graphs vertical scale was labeled
thus bolide the fragmentation rate Dube
said the rate at which new rocks are
being produced it's that a standard term
Pete wanted to know his tone was not so
much hostile as unnerved know Dube said
I made it up yesterday on the plane he
was tempted to add something like I am
allowed to coin terms but didn't want
things to get snarky this early in the
meeting
seeing that Pete had been silenced at
least for the moment Dube tried to get
back into his rhythm will see an
increasing number of meteorite impacts
some will cause great damage but overall
life is not going to change that much
but then he clicked again and the plot
bent sharply upward turning white we are
going to witness an event that I'm
calling the white sky it'll happen over
hours or days the system of discrete
planetoids that we can see up there now
is going to grind itself up into a vast
number of much smaller fragments they're
going to turn into a white cloud in the
sky and that cloud is going to spread
out click the graph continued shooting
upward rocketing up into a new domain
and turning red a day or two after the
white sky event will begin a thing I am
calling the hard rain because not all of
those rocks are going to stay up there
some of them are going to fall into the
Earth's atmosphere he turned to the
projector off this was an unusual move
but it snapped them all out of
PowerPoint hypnosis
forced him to look at him the age in the
back of the room were still thumbing
their phones but they didn't matter by
some Dube said I mean trillions the room
remains silent it is going to be a
meteorite bombardment such as the earth
has not seen since the primordial age
when the solar system was formed Dube
said those fiery trails we've been
seeing in the sky lately as the
meteorites come in and burn up there
will be so many of those that they will
merge into a dome of fire that will set
a flame anything that can see it the
entire surface of the earth is going to
be sterilized glaciers will boil the
only way to survive is to get away from
the atmosphere go underground or go into
space well obviously that is very hard
news if it is true the president said
they all sat and thought about it
silently for a period of time that might
have been one minute or five we will
have to do both the president said go
into space and underground obviously as
a ladder is easier yes we can get to
work building underground bunkers for
and she caught herself before saying
something in politic for people to take
refuge in Dube didn't say anything the
chairman of the Joint Chiefs of Staff
said dr. Harris I'm an old logistics guy
I deal in stuff how much stuff do we
need to get underground how many sacks
of potatoes and rolls of toilet paper
per occupant I guess what I'm asking is
just how long is the hard rain going to
last Dube said my best estimate is that
it will last somewhere between 5,000 and
10,000 years so that's the set up of the
book it's pretty early oh thanks
just to kind of give some intuition for
this the a couple years ago a meteorite
came in over Chile events in Russia
thank you I'm sure some of you saw
pictures of the fiery trail in the sky
maybe saw some of the dashboard video
that was posted on the internet and the
thing that was remarkable to me about
the dashboard video was that it pretty
much maxed out the video cameras it was
obviously much brighter than the Sun
well it turns out that some of the
people who were there who stood there
and watched this trail of fire go
overhead got sunburned so even though
the duration of the event was only a few
moments during that amount of exposure
they got sunburned badly enough that a
few days later they peeled so what that
tells you is that the light coming out
of that bow light was more like the
light of an arc welder and less like the
light of a candle so you can imagine
that if the sky were full of things
emitting that kind of radiation what
that would be like so anyway that is my
my set up to write an arc novel and I
won't go into a lot more detail about
what happens next since I don't want to
spoil everything but the we we followed
the saga of what happens next and we've
got some some cool illustrations that
were made for the book by Wetty
workshop in New Zealand including a new
one that we just released digitally
yesterday or the day before I can't
can't talk because I'm on book to her
someday someday that was not today and
so you can see it yes there's still in
the kind of an exclusive I think on io9
and Gizmodo
but eventually it'll kind of go up on
the website you can see it anywhere so I
didn't know if you wanted to do we're
going to talk or do questions okay okay
do you have a you want to start with
something o77 Yves I heard about the
seven moons but
feeling that's not the seven Eve's tell
us where the seven comes from well I'll
get ready for question seven is just a
magic number right so and it could have
been some other number but at some point
I figured out that seven Eve's was a
palindrome at that point it's like okay
I missed that I didn't get those
forward-backward all right
but it was released on on five 1915
which is also a palindrome publishers
they think of everything I got to see an
early version
not so well ladies early version of this
book because he sent it to Ryan feeling
and me and connection was revived and
restored some biotech in there and I
don't think I give away too much by
ASCII you talk about where the seven in
relation to biotech comes from oh yeah
the the the black-footed ferret yeah so
the the black-footed ferret is a
predatory animal that eats prairie dogs
and there used to be a lot of them
because there used to be a lot of
prairie dogs and then farmers came and
killed almost all of the prairie dogs
and so the the population of black
footed ferrets crashed and got as low as
seven I guess and so the I guess now
it's being rebuilt I don't know if
they're I don't know what the status of
it is but the the problem in general
when you're trying to build a population
back up from a very small bottleneck is
the loss of what's called heterozygosity
so genetic diversity in the species you
know which is kind of a fancy way of
talking about the incest problem so I
gathered that there have been some
efforts made to to address that by
intervening directly
and it's of monkeying around with with
their genetic code which is kind of the
only way you can get that hetero
zygosity back once it's been once it's
been lost so I probably butchered that
but at least that's the sort of
cartoonish understanding of it that that
this book is kind of based on because
what happens in the book is that there's
a similar bottlenecking phenomenon where
the total population of breeding humans
gets really reduced to a very small
number no prizes for guessing what that
number is and it has to be built back up
but unfortunately they've got access to
a fully featured genetic engineering lab
and somebody who knows how to use it and
so it leads to a number well to one
interesting conversation about about the
ethics of meddling with the human genome
what what the goals of that meddling
should be and and that kind of becomes
the basis for the the latter part of the
book I can fill in a little bit of the
what happened of the black-footed
ferrets that was all dead right black
footed ferrets went extinct twice and
they may go extinct again they were down
to just a few in South Dakota and people
were keeping an eye on this is an
obligate predator this is an animal that
eats only prairie dogs and so if there's
no prairie dogs there's no predator
that's it and that was the situation
that some prairie dogs bang I got and
there were these small population and
they were done in by canine distemper
they all died
so they'd gone extinct sorry was that
but then and the TT Wyoming of some dog
came brought in a dead ferret and
somebody said recently did where did
that come from they tracked it down and
they found thirteen still living wild
black footed ferrets it's a beautiful
little animal but yay long
totally active lives about a year and a
half but you know 60 years in a year and
a half it's fast cute charismatic and
they realized that probably they were
going to
so Fish and Wildlife took it into
captive breeding program which has now
been going for thirty years based in
Fort Collins Colorado and there's some
in various issues in the Washington zoo
and so on and all of those thirteen
animals just seven were able to
reproduce in a way that their genes then
went into the gene pool and so they had
the seven Eve's problem the seven
founders there's now have been probably
four thousand kits born and at this
point they're several hundred living
many of them in the wild so I'm still in
captivity but they have the inbreeding
problem that basically cousins not even
cousins anymore really close cousins are
mating with cousins and you're starting
to get kinky tails and not so good
reproduction and things like that
so US Fish and Wildlife came to revive
and restore knowing we're doing the
extinction they said you know can you
help prevent an animal from going
extinct and do some biotech manipulation
of these black footed ferrets to restore
their hetero zygosity in some fashion
I just wanted further story on that
which is that it turns out the frozen
zoo had cryopreserved
to black-footed ferrets over 30 years
ago this is in San Diego Zoo and those
two ferrets are not part of the seventh
oh great okay so we're now in the
process of moving toward cloning because
that's viable cells with viable DNA
cloning those two animals and we will
take it up to you potentially nine
founders and then other things are going
on in relation to disease and so on so
thank you yet again you're totally in
league with the long now foundation it's
all secret questions here right here
Kevin Kelly speak up and we should
repeat the questions out of the live
feed
universally reviled subgroups so are
there any subgroups today that are
universally you think might be existing
there any subgroups now Kevin Kelly
asked that might be that are universally
reviled now that will be of interest in
the future well of course now it's it's
not considered okay to just universally
reviled escrita
that kind of thing it used to be okay to
just write off whole slabs of the human
race as being just impossible to accept
and that is a good question man
the by universally reviled I mean so I
probably the example I was talking about
in that interview was the Puritans so I
mean in the Baroque cycles of the main
you know to the extent there's a main
character it's a guy named Daniel
Waterhouse who was a Puritan from a
family of Puritans and and you know it's
been a very long time since since the
word Puritan was was used in an admiring
way right I mean nobody uses even even
in at the time it was coined it was used
as a way of slamming you know unpopular
religious group so but the the peer at
the people who were who were derided as
being Puritans actually were some
amazingly creative people and they they
changed politics and you know they were
kind of forerunners of the the ethos of
entrepreneurialism and free enterprise
and that's true of some other groups
that were poorly thought of at the time
Jews Armenians some Indian groups and so
so that's all that's all past I would
have to think about it as to whether
there's anybody like that
I'll bet Kevin Kelly's got some in mind
that he doesn't you don't so much for
that yeah back here question I'll try to
repeat the question why don't you repeat
him at all or I didn't hear the first
part of it so okay so sometimes science
fiction is looked at not just as
entertainment there's a guidepost to the
future and was I thinking about that
when I wrote this I think I think one
has to be careful about that because if
it seems like you're being too
prescriptive or didactic in in a book
then people people just switch off right
so you have to be really careful about
that kind of thing the I I think the the
most I tried to do was to maybe
highlight or bring to people's
attentions some technologies or some
ideas that I personally find interesting
so like a minor example is that at one
point they make a ship out of ice they
get a piece of comment and they bring it
back and they they use it as structural
material to make a big ship spaceship
and they mix it with fibrous stuff to
make a thing called pykrete which is a
real thing if you mix sawdust and water
and freeze it you get this pretty strong
structural material that floats and
during World War Two there were there
was a plan to actually make unsinkable
aircraft carriers out of this stuff and
just basically rammed them up onto the
shore of Normandy unfortunately that
never happened but so you know so that
makes a that makes an appearance and
I've got another kind of abiding
interest in a lost branch of physics
which has to do with the physics of
moving chains which is related to the
physics of bullwhips and why they break
the sound barrier and so I ended up
working that in
but I had to be nudged into it I have a
friend in Seattle there's a British
mathematician Arthur champ renown who
read the early draft of the book and he
objected to something which was that in
late late in the book someone gets from
the surface of the earth to
geosynchronous orbit in a way that's
generally pretty graceful and it doesn't
involve rockets
you know uses big machines and
harvesting energy from the atmosphere
and kind of a different take on on how
they to get to orbit and but at one
point they they were using a rocket to
complete part you know one leg of this
journey and he he wasn't okay with that
that ruins the whole thing that's got to
go you know and so you've got to figure
out a way to eliminate that rocket burn
and so that's when I decided to try to
shoehorn in this this other kind of
physics having to do with with
essentially making big bull whips and
cracking them in a programmatic way to
to make big changes in velocity say a
little more about how the change stuff
works I need to see you move your hands
to get a sense of what the hell you're
talking about that the this is like a
canned 90 minute tirade that I can give
at any moment so you've really got to be
careful but the there was a Scottish
physicist named Aitken John Aitken who's
got a namesake in this book who was a
friend and a protege of the Thompson
brothers Lord Kelvin and James Thompson
and they had apparently noticed that if
you get a loop of chain moving fast like
there's some chain up there yeah so I
was looking around for sometimes roll up
doors have all right yeah we do hit yeah
well then yeah that's a good example
light one so if that got moving fast you
would see the loop then at the bottom
right next to your ear that would spread
out a little bit and become
as stiff acts like it's almost alive and
has to be kind of moving and he had
noticed this and he build a bunch of
machines in his parlor to to examine
this phenomenon and some of them used
hanging chains driven by a wheel at the
top and some of them yeah the
Exploratorium has one yeah so that this
all started with him one with the wheel
at the bottom that drives the thing
upward and there's all kinds of crazy
physical phenomena that arise from from
that physics and he was the first guy to
study it and figure it out and then the
next person who looked at it was a
French guy 50 years later in 1920s a guy
named car air who's an astronomer and he
had noticed that the sound the whip
makes when it cracks is just like the
sound made by a high-velocity rifle
bullet when it goes by you so this is a
Frenchman riding in the 20s about that
one senses maybe there's some unpleasant
experiences in his recent past made him
think of it but so he built a
contraption he came up he was the first
to come up with the idea that what whips
do is break the sound barrier and he
built a contraption to find out if that
was true and it's this amazing steampunk
thing that I want to reproduce one day
it's got he what he needed was to take
stroboscopic photos of the whip there
were no strobe lights so he made this
contraption consisting of these big
capacitors these big Leyden jars and he
would crank them up with a Wimshurst
machine until they were up to like
20,000 volts and then he had a what he
literally calls a guillotine which is a
plank that would fall down to vertical
rails and it would trip a series of
switches as it as it went by and he
could adjust the timing by moving the
switches up and down and each switch
would discharge one of these Leyden jars
across a spark gap that was the middle
of a parabolic reflector
illuminate the whip as he had a whip
cracking machine so as the whip was
cracking this thing would flash and make
you know I was in the dark so it would
make exposures on a photographic plate
and that almost enabled him to prove his
point but the it wasn't quite granular
enough but he knew where now he knew
where the crack was happening so he made
a new contraption which he made some
wooden disks the fat wooden disks that
were spinning at a very high velocity
and he painted them white and before
each experiment he would smoke them so
they were covered with soot and then he
would get them spinning right by the
crack of the whip and as the whip
snapped by the shock wave propagating
from its tip would blow the soot off of
the rim of the disk and make a white
streak on the disk and because the disk
is spinning it wasn't a vertical
perpendicular streak but it was a
helical it was an angled streak I mean
by measuring the angle he could read off
the velocity at which the thing was
moving so he does all this he pulls this
whole thing off and then he goes back to
Aikens work to get the physics and he
tells the whole story of it and kind of
is the first guy to to prove that and
then the the final paper not the final
but the last one I got interested in was
written in the late 40s by a couple of
German physicists at Girt thinkin and
the they had been contacted by an eye
doctor
at the clinic and of course the way
medicine works is that you know the
local doctors will solve all the cases
they know how to solve and if they find
something they can't help they refer it
up the food chain to the next doctor and
it is though things keep moving up and
so if you're the head of the eye clinic
at girth and gun it means you're the
most eminent ayah doctor in the
german-speaking world
so one day this this guy comes to work
and in his waiting room is a man who's
got floaters he can see little dark
specks floating around in his vision
which is a very common thing so this is
like if you're the most important
dermatologist in the world and somebody
comes to see you about a freckle right
he he looks into the guy's eye and he
sees tumbling around in the guy's
vitreous humor he sees little tiny metal
rods they're obviously metal they're
obviously man-made and they're just
floating around loose inside of his
eyeball which is perfectly undamaged
there's no no entry wound nothing like
that so he's completely mystified he
asked the guy you know what did you do
during the war were you in an explosion
there you know anything like that and
the guy goes no I I didn't fight you
know I was civilian well what do you do
for a living
well I Drive a truck well do you ever
like maybe stick your head out the
window or we're ever in a crash you know
or anything like that no nothing like
that doctor so eventually he had to give
up and and write it off as a mystery of
science but then a few months later a
few months later another guy shows up
same symptoms exactly the same thing no
explanation for it and then another and
another so he starts trying to put the
pieces together and figure out what is
the common thread among all of these
people and turns out the one thing they
all have in common is that their drivers
which by then meant driving trucks but
during the war because we had targeted
their the Germans a fuel production
there had been a lot of trucks lying
around that couldn't be operated because
there was no fuel so they had gone back
to hauling them behind animals and they
had had the improvised harnesses and
yokes and all that stuff because it was
all gone nobody had used it for decades
and that was all easily invented from
ropes and straps and whatever they had
lying around but the hard thing was
getting whips because whips have some
pretty specific properties that they
have to have if they're gonna crack
correctly but some genius figured out
that one thing they had all over Germany
by that point was collapsed two
buildings and a lot of those buildings
had running down the outside a braided
copper grounding cable and if you just
went up to one of them and cut off a
length of that stuff and you know did
the right motion you could get that
thing to crack like a whip and a thing
that a lot of novice whip crackers do is
that they'll jerk the whip toward him to
make it snap which is really dangerous
because it comes back at you but it's a
really easy way to get it to crack every
time and so the doctor said you know did
it ever happen when you were doing that
do you like but you know feel you know
one of these sharp pains in your eye and
they said yeah that happens sometimes
but you know you just kind of blink it
away and a few minutes later you know
it's like nothing ever happened so he
goes running across the campus to the
physics department and he buttonholes a
couple of physicists and he says is it
physically plausible that if you cracked
a copper grounding cable like a whip
that the tensile strength of the copper
out at the end would get exceeded the
point where it would snap and if so
would it would the pieces be going fast
enough that they could fly through the
air for a few feet and penetrate
somebody's eyeball and come to a stop
inside the vitreous humor so the
physicist you know I mean this is all
that whole story is in a footnote
it's a footnote on page 1 of this of
this paper and then the rest of the
paper is them working out all the
physics of whip cracking and proving
that you know all of those things could
could happen so as you can tell that's
been a kind of a personal obsession of
mine for
I'd say that story qualifies as stranger
than fiction
but speaking of fiction one question I
have back on the didactic you don't do
didactic novel writing you have been a
little didactic both the science fiction
novels that get written and the
hieroglyph idea was being grumpy about
you know endless negativity and current
science fiction and fantasy yeah I had
to clarify that a bit because books
written science fiction is very diverse
he can't generalize about it you
shouldn't I probably made a mistake
early on by generalizing a little too
much but the science fiction we see on
the screen is uniformly distil peein
gloomy dark stuff and that is really
getting on my nerves so we tried to
initiate a project to get some people to
write some more optimistic stuff who's
called hieroglyph it came out in
September I don't think so
I mean it's a topic of conversation now
the but I don't think there's any direct
traceable results from it yet but people
are talking about it yeah the science
fiction writers are relatively easy to
shame compared to some the other but I
would say that one thing on that is this
book involves the end of civilization
but it's not civilizations fault and all
those yeah it's a big difference all
exulting is is climate change or nuclear
or something like that so
finish your story two questions a small
one or the big one a small I wanted to
say more about what cracking into space
and the big one is next novel framing so
on the first question
no and it's I doubt that the whip
mechanism could do delta-v big enough to
to do an orbital launch but I do think
it could it could do delta-v is on the
order of you know a few hundred or even
a couple thousand meters a second which
is sort of the realm of of existing
whips and you know be easier to do in
the vacuum of space so if you envision a
future in which we've got a huge amount
of space architecture in place and
moving things around becomes a routine
operation then it makes sense instead of
having each thing you're moving be its
own independent rocket it makes sense to
just basically use these things as
transfer stations to to toss toss stuff
back and forth and then as to you know
how I use my time I've started on
another book which I'm a couple hundred
pages in I guess and then was there a
break between these two books at all I
was put down the pen I I tend to fall
into a foul mood when I'm not doing
something I'm not writing a book and so
I don't like to stop and also I'm so if
you know putting putting the long now
hat on for a second you know I am aware
that I will not live forever and so you
know hopefully I'll live for a while but
I wanted to break this habit of
stopping for a whole year you know
between had you've done that before yeah
pretty much
mm-hmm so so I just decided to keep
going I'm also working part-time for a
company called magic leap which is
making augmented reality hardware of a
novel type and so that's also taking up
a bunch of my my time as well
framing yourself into a novel which is
sort of the original question the idea
for this one sort of percolated for a
couple of decades right a decade and a
half is that usually the case that
you're you've got a number of things out
there percolating and yeah one sort of
comes to life or very much yeah like the
the origin of an 'litham was when Danny
asked me to and me and several other
people to make just back of napkin
sketches of what the clock might look
like and that was that I would have been
1999 because he wanted it for a
millennial webpage but I didn't start
writing and at them until 2005 maybe and
then reamed eaves based on the story of
the Philippine Filipino hacker who made
a virus in the early 2000s that went
viral very very rapidly over the whole
the whole world and so that was probably
another five to eight year gestation
period so yeah these things tend to kind
of sit there and ferment in the
background for quite a long time before
you know it's kind of like insects that
you know spend a long time in the larval
state and they come out and fly around
for you know a little while there's a
one story the artists tell each other
that may or may not relate you I'm
reading a wonderful memoir by Sally Mann
the
ographers called hold still and in it
she mentions that photographer she knows
and I guess other artists who sort of
have a big ambitious thing they're
working on and they're grinding away on
they're grinding away on it and it's
very exciting at the beginning is it's
all possibility and some of them are
starting to play out and you realize
you've got something that's live and
it's taking you somewhere and you're
completely excited but by the time you
get to the end of the project it's all
punctuation yeah grinding away and
getting the last misspelling out of it
or the print that's actually half a
decent compared to what's in the
negative all that kind of thing she said
what she'd run from some other artists
like I guess in Taiwan with you what's
the name that it's the healthy thing for
an artist to do is as you get to that
tiresome end game have something else
starting to crank up that is already
getting you excited again yeah so you
don't have to spend a whole lot of time
and I can't believe this is dragging on
so long can I just stop it I hate myself
all that but you can go on to a new mode
of excitement and then in your spare
time finish the punctuation on the
previous work is that what you're
finding this time around well it's
always been been the case and it used to
be I would just get so distracted by the
punctuation literally that I wouldn't
even try to start something but you know
the more I do this the more I realize
that I can get bits of productive time
out if I kind of budget my time well and
so yeah I'm just trying to waste as
little time as possible here so so we've
got a question from the live stream
we'll give a quick shout out to we've
got a few dozen members and donors that
are listening from hopefully all over
the world right live streamers and we've
got a few questions from them I'll give
you one right now Alec asked so if I if
a catastrophe like what happens in 70s
were to happen in ten or a hundred years
how should we be preparing for it today
are there things that are going on now
that that that are examples of
preparation for I guess
this type of event or something similar
what are your thoughts on that well the
the part of the essence of the thing
that happens in seven aids it's so weird
and unpredictable that there's no way we
could have prepared for it which it's
almost an essential feature of an art
story whoa this came out of nowhere we
you know it's too late you know we have
to have to build an ark so no I mean I
think the best we can do is is maintain
those features of the society that make
us adaptable and flexible and able to to
come up with with new solutions rapidly
David Deutsch writes about this really
well and the beginning of infinity so
what what features a culture has to
possess in order to be capable of
dealing effectively with new stuff so
that that's his most recent non-fiction
book the beginning of infinity what else
you got
so Donna Theresa asks during the
research and writing process what did
you find seem to be an essential
cultural difference between a
spacefaring people versus a terrestrial
people how does that play into the book
well I mean the the look there's a
there's a really broad generalization
that has been made about the difference
between American culture and Canadian
culture so it's it's a generalization
it's probably wrong it's it's very
simplistic but it's kind of interesting
which is that Canada was so huge and so
cold and so you know such a vast area of
wilderness that you you couldn't do
anything with it in terms of white
person's civilization without
essentially stringing it together with
railways and-and-and
kind of having a big a large
governmental program to to render the
place habitable at least by white people
whereas in the United States you know it
was seems to have been more of a just go
out there and do something kind of place
the it's it's an ineluctable feature of
people living in space that the go at
your own mentality is not going to work
it's not going to work it's got to be
more the building big infrastructure
everyone getting along with each other
in kind of a reasonable way and keeping
the the individualistic tendencies kind
of under control so I think that would
be true of any culture that tried to
live in space for a long time you just
can't go off by yourself and do stuff
there it's that way most of the
characters in the book are female well
there's there's been a lot of research
done on sort of long-term living in in
space and there's again we're we're kind
of moving into generalization territory
but the there are some ways in which in
which women are thought to be maybe a
better fit for long-term space travel
and part of it is the their gonads are
on the inside so less exposed to to
radiation and if on the whole if you're
smaller you need less food and less
oxygen so it's really simple stuff like
that and you know for whatever reason
you know cultural training or
what-have-you
it it seems like living together in in
in a confined space for a long time
just doesn't seem to be a guy thing so
again generalizations but just say that
that you know people have have kind of
thought about gender in space and
according to them this isn't a terribly
far-fetched idea so there you are a
novelist writing inside a bunch of
female characters and you're not female
and you didn't do any hormone treatment
so what do you know of yeah so you make
all that up or you listen carefully to
women or how did you do that well I
guess just trying to to listen and just
to read a lot use some common sense I
don't know some of your female early
readers had advice on those matters or
not some of them yeah Andrew so thinking
in thousands of years what's easy what's
hard
yeah well the you know there's only a
few things that last that long but a few
human things physical things can last
that long pretty easily but but human
institutions you know companies don't
last that long
families don't last that long some some
things that last that long are cultures
religions there are some universities
that have been around for on the order
of a thousand years cities yeah so so
naturally one tends to think in terms of
those kinds of institutions when
and and and and you can see that pretty
clearly in in anathan where you know
those are the institutions that that the
feature prominently in that book and in
the case of in the case of seven Eve's
it's a different situation and so things
like cities and in religions are kind of
out of the picture for a while but but
there is a cultural continuity that's
preserved over that time which is a very
conscious artificial thing that is is
brought about by the decisions of the
founders of the different cultures or
races in the book they've got specific
agendas that they talk about in an
explicit way and their conversation is
recorded for the ages and people are
still watching that webcam footage 5,000
years later so it's very strongly
self-reinforcing in that way I'd say
this is the strongest novelistic case
ever of the novelistic idea that
character is destiny at the scale you
speak of questioning back just so we
know okay how about right here
totally inspired by a concept that you
brought in and then become a scientist
and focus and that in some cases don't
want to care just here question about is
inspiring teenagers something you have
in mind well I've been doing it long
enough now that you know there's this
like it at the reading last night a
number of people came up and said you
know things like I read your books when
I was a kid and it inspired me to become
a software engineer or a cryptographer
or whatever so I'm getting a lot of that
now and which makes me feel incredibly
old especially when the person saying it
appears middle-aged today but they don't
I I think that for anything to happen
they have to actually read the book all
the way through and they're not going to
do that if it's not a good story
a good yarn with good characters and so
everything else is secondary to that so
that's what I was kind of getting at
when talking about being didactic the if
you are fulfilling the first
responsibilities of telling a good story
that people enjoy reading then that
gives you a little bit of leeway to you
know to maybe sneak in a few
inspirational moments or or ideas for
people to think about but it's got to be
done somewhat somewhat cautiously
I did that inspired people back here in
blue vast last question this is it okay
well I hear all the time from from
people who who tell me that they're
they're trying to do it and they all
mean different things it turns out so
some of them are thinking about the
hardware of it some of the software some
about education so that's a cool thing
that people have not just one idea of
what it is a whole spectrum of ideas and
so I just smile and nod because I don't
want to so privileged any one particular
idea of what it should be you know the
you know the the use of technology and
education is a little tricky because it
can lend itself to sort of facile you
know we'll just buy a bunch of hardware
and you know parachuted into classrooms
and then everything will be awesome
which you know that that approach
doesn't work very well so you know see
it's
education is no joke it's a it's a hard
thing to to bring together the right set
of conditions needed to to make it work
and you know in the end nothing seems to
trump the influence of the home
environment on on people's ability to
learn just like there's all this kind of
research which is like simultaneously
inspiring and horrifying to the effect
that the number of words a kid hears in
the first couple years of their life is
pretty determinative of what they'll be
able to do with their brain for the rest
of their life and there was actually a
big internet you know fake actually came
up with a an acronym for this fake findt
a fake internet moral panic there was a
Finn pack Uppal of weeks ago about this
this researcher in the UK who had
suggested I'm sure in a tongue-in-cheek
way or in an effort to make a point that
that affluent educated parents should
stop reading to their kids so much
because it was giving their you know
provably demonstrable it was giving them
an unfair advantage you know over over
kids who didn't get that at that
treatment and you can imagine you can
imagine what happened on the internet
when you said I mean maybe maybe he was
serious I don't know but I I sort of
doubt it so the so that that trumps
everything else so much
that it makes me permanently a little
skeptical of efforts to do anything in
addition to or outside of of that family
environment which is somewhat depressing
way to end this but but but that's kind
of how I see it IIIi don't know how to I
don't know how that changed I know that
there are people working on it trying to
to to reach out to parents who maybe
were reared in a different tradition of
how to raise your kid and get them to
talk to their kids more you know maybe
that's a maybe that's something I don't
know anyway well and there yeah and I
have to offer you the challenge going on
the long now challenge coin it advises
you to carpe millennium tact which I'd
say you already do better than most
thank you very much
[Applause]
[Music]